so let's say that this house has been on
the market for a couple of weeks and the
asking price is three hundred and ten
thousand dollars and you say well you
know this looks like the type of house
and you're in the market to buy a house
you said hey this is a type of house
that I can imagine me and my family
living in I would like to buy this house
but you think you know this price has
been on the market for a couple of weeks
I maybe I think I could get a better
deal than this so you decide to make an
offer you decide to make an offer for
let's say a little bit less for $300,000
so the question is how do you go or how
does your agent go about actually making
an offer well the way it goes is you
don't just walk up to the seller or the
sellers agent and say okay we're going
to offer you $300,000 because they don't
know whether you're you're serious they
don't know whether you actually have the
money to do it whether you are in a
position to do it or whether you're just
kind of you know playing around or just
wasting their time and so to prove that
you're not wasting their time you create
or you you fill out an offer contract
and offer a contract so let's think
about what should go or what might go in
and offer contract offer offer contract
so you're likely your agent if you're
using an agent or even a real estate
attorney or you can even find some of
these forms on the web you would create
a contract and there's some basic
information that you would want you
would obviously want info info on the
property what's its address the property
who's who's buying yourself so the buyer
and the seller this is just kind of know
hey what do y'all what is this contract
about it's about this property and who's
getting into this into this contract and
then you'd want to put some information
about the actual offer so you would put
your offer in you'd say okay I'm going
to offer $300,000 offer
$300,000 and then you also want to prove
that look you're not just you know
you're not just playing around with them
that you're serious about that this is
offer is made in earnest and so you will
offer you will give a deposit when you
make this offer cottage or it's typical
to give a deposit so your deposit and it
will vary the higher the deposit the
better because it's it shows the more
earnest you are the more serious that
you are about actually going through
with this offer contract it's typical
for these deposits to be anywhere
between I've seen you know 1% 2% 3% 4%
5% of the actual home price 3% is what
I'm most familiar with but it doesn't
have to be 3% it's really this is just
an indicator to the seller that you're
serious about this so you're going to
write a check right now along with the
offer contract for let's say say 3% of
the offer price so 3% of $300,000 is
nine $9,000
that's a $9,000 check some places it's
not a percentage some people say okay
you just give $1,000 and give $2,000
whatever it is but this money once again
this is a check that you're writing with
the offer contract this shows that you
are serious about this that if for
whatever reason you don't meet your end
of the contract then the seller might be
able to just keep this money so this
shows so this is this shows that you are
serious this shows that you are serious
right here that they should take you
seriously and that they should go
through the process of trying to I guess
close on this property and we'll talk in
future videos more about what closing is
now you're probably think a look I'm
just not going to buy this outright I've
toured the home I like it I like the
neighborhood it seems to be in good
condition
but I don't know for a fact that it's in
good condition unless I have a chance to
inspect it unless I have a chance to get
some experts in there and make sure that
the house is in good condition and to
make sure of that it's typical to throw
some contingencies in your offer
contract contingencies contingencies now
the most typical contingencies are
things like inspections so you might
want to inspect for termites you want to
inspect the foundation you want to
inspect the plumbing the electrical and
make sure that it's all the up-and-up if
some if something comes up in the
inspect
that's you know makes this house not
what you thought it was it allows you to
get out of this contract and hopefully
get your deposit back now other things
that you might want to put a contingency
on well you think that you're going to
be able to get $300,000 maybe you have
saved enough for a deposit you save
let's say 20% of this so you have saved
say $60,000 or maybe you save 60 maybe
save 70 or 80 thousand dollars because
you also need some extra money for
closing costs and whatever else and
we'll talk about that in future videos
and maybe to buy furniture also you save
sick you save 70 or 80 thousand dollars
but the remainder of it you're going to
need to borrow and you're going to
borrow it from a bank the bank has
written a letter to you saying hey you
know based on your income and your
credit score we we feel we've we've
pre-approved your loan we think you're
going to get the loan but that's not the
same thing as actually getting the loan
something might happen the bank might
realize that they didn't notice
something about you or the finance the
financing conditions might change in
between the time that you got your
pre-approval and the time that you
actually need your loan so another
typical contingency that you might have
is a financing contingency saying look I
really do want to buy this house but I'm
clearly not going to be able to buy it
unless I get some financing and then
other things that might be there are
things like insurance why would you need
a contingency on insurance and this one
is this one's less typical so I'll put a
little asterisks there well there might
be it might be a place that has a lot of
floods and the old owner had flood
insurance just because they already
owned it but now the the insurance
companies aren't issuing new insurance
because it's so prone to flooding or
something like that so flooding
insurance might be in there there's a
clear title is obviously something that
you would that you would need if you
want to if you want to buy this house or
that you you probably should need and
once again there's other videos on that
so these are all things that if for
whatever reason the house if these
things fall through that it allows you
to unwind it now if you're in a really
hot real estate market where there's
many many people bidding on the same
property and some of them are coming
with you know really really juicy offers
where they're maybe they're offering to
paid in cash or they're offering other
things then it's not it's not a typical
to have fewer contingencies because
remember from the sellers point of view
they want the most serious the most
serious buyer and if someone is saying
if someone's willing to waive their
contingencies or like hey look I know
this is crazy but I'm just willing to
you know get the house in whatever
condition it is that's a lot more
attractive to the seller because the
seller feels good it won't that the
transaction won't fall through because
of one of these things but that's in a
very very very hot real estate market in
a more typical real estate market and I
suggest you talk to people and Realtors
other people in the industry to figure
out what's going on in your market it's
more typical to have stuff like this
especially the inspections the financing
and the title now the last part of it
and I'm glazing over a lot of details in
future videos we might actually look at
an actual offer contract you would want
to throw out the closing date so the
closing date closing date so maybe this
offer contract let's may say It's Made
on let's say it's made on October 15th
of 2015 and let's say that you want to
close so you want all of this stuff to
get done and you actually want to get
the seller there the full amount of the
money and you want to get the title to
the house let's say you want to have it
in two months so 1215 2015 and so and
once again from a seller's point of view
the closer in this closing date the more
that they feel good that this
transaction is actually going to happen
so if you wanted to make a very tempting
offer to a seller you would have as few
contingencies as possible and you would
make this closing date as soon as
possible but if it's not a superhot real
estate market you don't need to go
through through all that trouble and
it's fairly prudent to get inspections
and have contingencies on all of these
or things like this not necessarily all
of them but things like this